arrêtez vous ne vous mettez vous debout
on commence à lui et se déplacer ou
encore respecter son adversaire cette
année la section de judo ce1 ce2 va
apprendre de nouvelles règles et de
nouvelles prises l'an dernier la saison
a été impactée par le coronavirus les
enfants sont donc heureux de retrouver
leurs camarades et leurs kimonos
on a fait quelques prises on a fait des
déplacements et j'ai trouvé que c'est
bien et j'aime un peu près tout ya des
prises
on a ri une année dernière phase que
savourer longtemps comme un prix en
effet des cours ont repris le 7
septembre avec un groupe de huit enfants
plus ou moins débutants ont fait voir
que j'ai donc c'est l'entraidé entre eux
mais ceux qui ont fait un peu plus doux
depuis un an deux avec des débutants qui
commence cette année
donc ils ont appris les bases à savoir
un peu la chute et les déplacements qui
permet de ne bouger à 2 sur le tapis
savoir tenir le docu mono avec 40 %
d'inscriptions en moins des places sont
encore disponibles pour s'initier au
judo
cette baisse d'adhérents est
certainement dû à la crainte de l'aco
vide
les parents n'ont pas encore tous
confiance avec dont je pense que dans
quinze jours trois semaines on sera où
on en est au point de vue des effectifs
d'une pas de la réinscription des
enfants et pourtant toutes les mesures
sanitaires sont respectées pour passer
un moment de détente
on passe par les vestiaires on ne s'y
attarde pas on vient directement sur le
tapis le judo club de
voisins-le-bretonneux accueille des
enfants mais aussi des adultes
vous pouvez encore vous inscrire pour
espérer un jour atteindre la ceinture
noire